hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Doctor Strange non-spoilery review
basically like the Rick and Morty entry
into the Marvel Universe so here we go
you might not believe it but Dan Harmon
actually consulted on certain aspects of
the story just to help them because the
way Rick and Morty works is this really
complicated multiverse based show so
Kevin Feige and Scott Derrickson brought
him in to talk about some of the crazier
stuff they wanted to try in the Marvel
Universe all save some of that for my
spoilery video next week but you can
just imagine which parts of the movie
Morty I'm gonna need you to take those
infinity gems and shove them way up your
butt the funny thing about the Doctor
Strange character when you go way back
to the 1960s which is basically where
this pulls from Steve Ditko like very
classic Doctor Strange particularly with
the visuals is that his origin story his
character reads a lot like the Iron Man
character so the danger going into this
movie which they totally avoided is in
completely recycling the plot from that
first Iron Man movie which I thought
they did a really good job of Kevin
Feige said this interesting thing where
he said that the journey that Iron Man
goes on in that first Iron Man movie
actually isn't that big so they wanted
to take Doctor Strange on a much more
complete character arc like even though
you might know a little bit about the
comic book origin story really rich
surgeon to sorcerer supreme it
really is a much bigger shift in his
character then Tony Stark goes through
during that first Iron Man movie but I
thought they did a really good job of
weaving mysticism and the really weird
stuff from the Doctor Strange comics
into the more cookie cutter Marvel
Universe like you go to see an Avengers
movie you know what you're gonna get so
this is really trying to push into new
territory like look how weird things can
get in one of the biggest ways they do
that is with really amazing use of 3d so
if you have the opportunity to go see
the movie in 3d next to avatar you know
way back in 2009 I'll say this is one of
the best uses of 3d in a movie so
they've really had fun with that idea
you may have seen it in some of the
trailers like where they start flipping
the screen so the way
they constructed the film the way they
visualized the story is very different
from the traditional Avengers MCU films
but the important stuff
what about Benedict Cumberbatch's Doctor
Strange performance what about the
character that he's created they've been
teasing that he's supposed to be very
important to all the movies going
forward so I feel like the real point of
failure would be in his performance like
Robert Downey jr. fully became the Iron
Man character so much he's so embodied
that character that people don't think
of Tony Stark when they look at Robert
Downey jr. they just see him and think
of Iron Man so if he were to leave
Marvel like not resign any more
contracts and not be in movies he would
completely destroy Marvel's ability to
use that character like Robert Downey
jr. and Tony Stark are the same person
it's not like an actor playing a
character he is Tony Stark so that's
kind of the impossible hurdle that you
have to jump over with any new
characters they introduce Benedict
Cumberbatch is an amazing actor I did
think the English accent was a little
bit weird even though it's accurate
Doctor Strange is an American so he
would speak with an American accent but
I do kind of feel this is one thing they
could have changed from the comics there
were a couple impossible situations with
the movie which I'll explain in a second
that they tried to tiptoe around so I
understand if like when you first heard
him speak with the accent it was just a
little bit weird but I don't think it
drugged the movie down and I do think
that Benedict Cumberbatch was able to do
the Robert Downey jr. 2 Ironman
transformation it's really the Stephen
strange part I feel like he doesn't
quite get to there's like this x-factor
that makes Robert Downey jr. so lovable
in all the movies that he's in so you
don't really mind what he's doing like
he just has this power over audiences
that makes them love him so much so I
feel like Benedict Cumberbatch you know
hopefully he'll get to that point in the
Marvel Universe because that's really
what you have to do like when you don't
get there that's when people start to
nitpick the other little things like the
accent or the jokes that don't land and
one of the only other weird aspects of
the film that I don't feel like quite
hammers home as well as it does in some
of the other Marvel movies is some
awkwardly placed jokes that he has while
he's still Stephen strange so Stephen
strange the character isn't quite so
funny he
gets funnier once he becomes dr. strange
in the funniest line in the movie
arguably comes from Maz Nicholson's
character so you guys can let me know if
you agree but I feel like they can work
on the humor just a little bit for the
next time Doctor Strange appears so you
know no spoilers for post-credit scenes
or anything like that there are two make
sure you stay through the entire film
through the credits but I'll talk about
that when I post a spoiler Easter Egg
video but I feel like the other like
biggest complaints that I've heard that
people have had have been not enough of
the actors that they really like in the
film so there are a bunch of characters
and just like any Marvel movie there are
certain people that get more screen time
than others so there's some like really
amazing actors like Benjamin Bratt that
have really small roles that you're like
please you know please bring him back in
the sequel we want to see way more of
this so even like the director scott
derrickson has said is there are a bunch
of characters that he would love to
double down on in future movies that
they just didn't have time to get to in
this movie so I you know obviously you
can imagine the most important
characters get the most screen time you
have Tilda Swinton Benedict Cumberbatch
Chiwetel Ejiofor Rachel McAdams who even
though she's actually a pretty important
character for Stephen strange isn't as
big as you would think she would be in
the movie
Wong Mask Nicholson's character Casilla
as' and there are a lot of people I've
seen you know who have trouble following
casillases storyline but I feel like
it's mostly non comic-book people which
is a typical problem from Marvel movies
where you know you have like a big
villain character somebody from the
comics who you know comic book people
are familiar with so even if they don't
like completely spell out their plan in
great excruciating detail you just hear
words like multiverse other dimensions
and your mind kind of makes the leap to
the characters that populate those
places so you're fine but if you haven't
read the comics it's a little confusing
so like if you took your parents to see
the movie they you know they might
follow Mads Mikkelsen because he's an
amazing actor but they might not fully
understand the ramifications of what
he's doing and how big it is but I feel
like that's okay it's a typical comic
book movie problem where you have an
underdeveloped villain so without giving
spoilers there's a big character that's
a villain from the comics in the movie
that is not a villain in this movie that
will probably be the villain of the next
movie and it'll become more of a Winter
Soldier style movie that focuses more on
the villain character so it's really a
moot point if you're a big comic book
movie fan you're kind of used to this
and you're following this overarching
Infinity Gauntlet storyline you're
looking for certain language characters
saying certain names from the comics so
in that way Doctor Strange is like
packed with a bunch of stuff that you've
never seen before in a Marvel movie so
this is one of those Marvel movies that
you like really have to be alert for to
catch all the easter eggs because it's
largely unfamiliar territory in the MCU
so bunch of new characters bunch of new
locations bunch of new concepts you know
particularly multiverse multiple
dimensions so even though the movie
might seem like Pink Floyd laser
lightshow that you would take drugs to
go see make sure you see it at least
once when you're like fully alert so
that you can pick up all the Easter eggs
in the background in the sanctum
sanctorum is amazing it's just a lot
like Odin's vault there's stuff all over
the background it'll take like three or
four times watching the movie to catch
it all in without completely giving it
away they were a bunch of different
Marvel directors that use the sanctum
after they finished filming the movie to
film different scenes with other
characters like they waited to tear down
the set so that other directors could
have some fun with it
so the tease I will leave you with is
that James Gunn himself shot the next
four Stanley cameos so he shot cameos
with Stanley for other people's movies
and it was all in the same place so just
be on the lookout when you go see the
movie so that's really only the
beginning so there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs that I'll talk about in
another video
that'll post like next Thursday or
Friday so be sure to subscribe to get it
let me know what kind of Doctor Strange
videos you want once everybody's had a
chance to see it there's like so much
stuff that we have to talk about for
phase three there's like so many videos
that I wanted to make this week that you
can't really
until people see the movie because it
gets into spoilers but you can imagine
it has to do with Avengers it has to do
with guardians of the galaxy
Thanos Infinity Gauntlet stuff so
there's just like a lot of stuff that's
going on with the Doctor Strange
universe of characters and then you have
like all the other larger Avengers stuff
that's going on to the MCU so while I
don't think that Doctor Strange is gonna
out gross the Iron Man films or it's not
gonna out gross the Avengers films
I think creatively I gave it a lot of
bonus points because it tried to do a
lot of different things like they did a
really good job of not making it this
cookie cutter movie made on a factory
assembly line so as of now phase 3 is
looking really cool I'm so jazzed up
about Thor 3 I can't wait to see how
weird it is they've been teasing that
it's so different from the other Thor
movies that it's not really a sequel
even though technically it's still a
sequel but let me know in the comments
what was your favorite thing about
Doctor Strange and if you're gonna post
spoilers just be sure to like you know
use the spacebar to go below the fold so
that you know people don't see it
because it's gonna be another week or so
until the rest of the world sees the
film but then we can talk all about it
it's gonna be so much fun so just a
reminder if you haven't seen it in 3d
like if you've already seen it once I
would recommend that you see it in 3d if
you have the chance but what's gonna
happen next is is I'll be posting a
Suicide Squad Joker cut video there's
like a Joker cut of the movie like an
extended cut with a bunch of Joker stuff
that didn't make it into the final cut
of the film that I'll do a video for
explaining Jared Leto like you know kind
of went on record saying like I feel
deceived you know there was all this
Joker stuff that we could I feel like I
was gonna be in the movie and I was
barely in there so we'll do video
explaining what that's about that we'll
post tonight so why you guys wait for
that video to post you can click down
here for that you know big behind the
scenes Thor Ragnarok video and you can
click here to watch the guardians of the
galaxy trailer again thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you
tonight there are two types of beings in
the universe